people have been making some very good
celebrity look-alikes in the style field
character creator Adam Driver obviously
made by kazonflix on the Starfield
subreddit this is a pretty spot on
Sylvester Stallone I'd like to see it
from the front this one's made by the
Fassbender on the stockfield subreddit
it's Mike from Breaking Bad this one was
made by someone called heroines I feel
like this one's like not 100 there but
it's recognizable there is it's the ears
obviously a nice take on Obama but the
person said they're playing as a
diplomat it's made by Buttercup z575
okay I think this one is my favorite
obviously Willem Dafoe made by strida390